Welcome to the Innate
Immunity 1 and
2 lectures.
These lectures expand
on the previous
semester in Immunity
1 and Immunity
2 lectures. So if
you're feeling like
you need to go back
and review those
to refresh
yourself and make
sure you have that basis
to develop further
information from
here, that might
be not a bad idea.
These are the objectives
that we need to cover.
So basically we're
going to be able to
compare and contrast
innate and adaptive immune
response and then
we'll go into more
focusing on the innate
immune response and talk
about the first and
second line of defenses
and different components
of those. We'll
focus predominantly on
the innate processes
of inflammation,
psychocytosis, fever,
the interferon
response, and complement
option. In those we're
going to be talking
about the role of
cytokines and all these
different NMA processes
and specifically
discuss and talk about
the role of pattern
recognition receptors
and the importance
of those in initiating
the inflammatory
response. And at the end
we'll talk about some
deficiencies of innate
immunity and the
type of diseases that
this could lead to.
One of the key things
and we have discussed
this last semester is
to distinguish between
innate and adaptive
immune response and
some of the key differences
and so of course
obviously they're both
part of the immune
response but then we
have to distinguish
the importance of one
of them is that there's
a lot of overlap
between the two but
remember this this type
of distinction is a
little bit artificial
because and in regard
to the immune system
it all functions as a
unit but there are
ways to distinguish the
response of each and
there's typically a
different timeline set
up for each. So usually
the innate immune
response is always X
first. And then if
things are not resolved,
the adaptive
immune response
comes in.
So again, there's a,
you know, they're very
common. It's all part
of the same response.
There's a lot of
cells that overlap and
activate and one lead
to the other. And
there's a positive
impact between the two.
You know, obviously
macrophages, for example,
regulate the
inflammatory response and
they're responsible
for the innate immune
response but at the same
time they do present
antigen activate the
helper cells which
then activates the
adaptive immune response
so keep that in mind
some of the key things
differences are listed
in this table so for
example the innate
immune response is non
-specific quality
adaptive is very specific
the innate immune
response doesn't
really learn from
the encounter it's
the same there's no
memory that develops
like the adaptive
immune response.
Also the innate
immune response is
instantaneous and it's
always available while
the adaptive immune
response, at least
the initial one or the
primary, is usually
slow. The secondary,
after it learns
and memory develops,
becomes much faster.
The innate immune
response, as we've
discussed before,
is divided into the
first line and second
line defense. The
third line defense
being the adaptive.
And that's kind of
similar how the pathogen
would go through the
body. You have the
first line responding
first and if things
are settled you'll
stay there and if not
you'll escalate the
second line and so on
the first line is
basically the physical
chemical and the
biological barriers that
we have things like the
skin earwax defenses
stomach acid our normal
flora etc there's
also a chart on the
side highlighting
our table actually sorry
has all the different
kind of a breakdown
a nice chart for
you guys to see all
this information. The
second line involves
inflammation, fever,
complement, interferon,
phagocytosis, and
natural ketocytes,
and we'll discuss
each of these.
So let's talk about
each of these barriers.
So the physical barriers
involve the skin,
and of course the
skin is an excellent
barrier. It basically
protects us from
many, many organisms.
A good example to
remember is even with
all the immune system
intact, if you
have a burn victim,
they can typically die
from infection simply
because they've
lost a good chunk of
their skin, despite
the fact that every
other part of their
body is still intact.
Mucous membranes
also trap organisms,
that's what mucus is
for, it just basically
fixates doesn't allow
to move respiratory
tract you know have
cilia hair mucus all
that trap same thing
you know urinary
tract with the constant
flushing of urine
it actually helps
with moving organisms
away from the you
know kidneys and so on
so the physical areas
are so important um
in going back to skin
a little bit again the
skin is basically in
that in its natural
state with the
exception of things like
parasites, which some of
them can actually break
the intact skin.
Organisms typically cannot
break the intact skin,
so they would need
a cut or wound or
something to gain access.
The chemical barriers,
which is part of the
first line of defense,
constitute things
like our pH in different
parts of the body,
our skin, stomach,
and the vaginal tract,
for example, or acidic.
Different levels of
acidity, but they're
all acidic and that's
predominantly to discourage
bacterial growth.
As you know from
last semester and the
bacterial physiology
lecture bacteria does not
like acidic environments
prefer pH closer
to 8 and so by
naturally many of our
environments are inhibitory
to bacterial growth
also our many molecules
are secreted as part
of the first line of
defense a lot of micro
sedal molecules like
lysozyne which breaks
down the peptocolligan
layer, defensins,
calvacidins, RNAs and
DNAs which break down
you know genomes and
even salt in itself
can dry out the cells
and take water from
inside of a biosmosis
and all these can be
very inhibitory to
microbial growth and our
microbiome serves as
an excellent defense
and inhibits other
organisms from growing
whether it's bacterial
or fungal and you
know people have been
talking and discovering
how important the
microbiome and the
balance in the microbiome
and many different
diseases so you know
previously we used to
think because it's
good for natural health
and now we realize
it's important for you
gut health and there's
a lot of relationships
now between
disturbance to the
microbiome and you know
neurologic diseases
like parkinson's
disease and others
so the more and more
we understand about
our biological defense
the many bacterium
that reside in the
yeast that reside
in our body the more
we appreciate that
before the second line
consists of inflammation
fever, the interferon
response, the
component response,
phagocytosis,
and the role of
natural kills. And
next we'll discuss
all of these.
Let's talk about
inflammation, a very
important response
which actually
clues the body that
there's something
going on. So
inflammation is very
necessary. It's response
to tissue damage,
any kind of tissue
damage, physical,
infectious,
anything else.
The hallmark of
inflammation or what
triggers inflammation
is the release
of the inflammatory
mediators or
chemicals such as,
as you already know,
histamine, complement
protein C5A,
and two endocrosis
factor alpha.
These are just a
few, as you know,
there's tons of
other inflammatory
chemicals and cytokines
that are there.
How the inflammatory
response is triggered,
we'll talk about
that in a little bit,
but these chemicals
are essential for that.
And, you know, as
you already know,
the cardinal signs
for inflammation are
heat, pain, redness,
and swelling,
and the fifth one
is loss of function.
The terminology for
those came from the
Latin words calor,
dolor, reborn, and tumor.
And very important
to remember that the
inflammatory response
in our body is
coordinated by
macrophages. So macrophages
regulate the inflammatory
response and that's
very essential to
understand. They're
the one that started
it. They're the one
that invite other cells
through the release
of different chemicals
like TNF-alpha.
What happens when
the inflammation
starts is you see
increase in blood
supply into the
area, you see
increase in capillary
permeability,
all important to invite
different players
to come to this
region. You also see
increase in leukocyte,
white blood cell
chemotaxis, so attraction
of specific cells to
an area and what
cells are attracted is
typically determined by
the type of chemokine
receptors that are
there and we'll
discuss that a little
bit and if we get fast
clearance of the
foreign substance or the
antigen then that's
basically an acute
form of inflammation
and things are resolved
but sometimes as
you know antigens
persist and that results
in a chronic instinctive
inflammation, which
tend to be a little
more damaging,
obviously, than acute.
On the table right
here, it shows
you the migration
per day and the
quantity of these
cells as inflammation
starts. Of
course, initially,
neutrophils arrive,
usually a set of
inflammatory response,
and then after that,
different type of
mononuclear cells like
microfluidus or monocytes
can come to the site
then if that
doesn't get resolved
especially if they made
a new response does not
resolve you end up
recruiting t helper
cells which then can
activate the humoral or
the cell mediated in
your response keep
in mind that remember
macrophages are the
regulators of
inflammation so they're
always you know
macrophages are resident
monocytes so in any
tissue there's already
macrophages and more of
them may be recruited
but they'll always
be there initially
so they may invite
neutrophils and they
may invite more
macrophages or they invite
t helper cells
but they're
always there
in that tissue
one of the key
cytokines that involve
inflammation of
course tnf alpha is
one of the major
ones truly plays a
very important role.
Allios 1 is also
another one and
interferon gamma.
So typically most of
these cytokines are
released from white
blood cells in
response to activation
and signal transduction
pathways. Signals
transduction pathways
that are controlled
by a transcription
regulator referred
to as NF-kappa B. A
very important master
switch basically
with the immune
response and critical to
understand how its
role in activation of
different elements of
the immune response.
Just a few comments
about TNF-alpha and
it's role again the
major major player in
the inflammatory
response it can be it's
actually pro
thrombotic it promotes
leukocyte adhesion and
migration it activates
macrophages and so
it's actually released
by macrophages and
activate macrophages
it's kind of a
positive feedback loop
and it will promote
hematopoiesis
as well as lymphocyte
development
There are four major
types of what's referred
to as plasma enzyme
systems which all
contribute to different
inflammatory mediators.
So all these systems
you see right here, the
complement system,
the kinin system, the
flabolitic or plasmin
system, and the clotting
system, all release
chemicals which actually
can cause inflammation.
So they all contribute
to the many different
inflammatory
remediators that we secrete
in our body. And it's
important to have
redundancy in that system
in case something fails.
We can always spot
and trigger an
inflammatory response. So
we'll talk about each
of these a little bit.
So quickly discussing
the plasmin system.
It's basically a
system that's involved
predominantly in tissue
repair and remodeling.
Plasmin is an enzyme
that actually dissolves
fibrin after the
production of a blood clot.
plasminogen is
converted to plasmin
and then plasmin
destroys fiber.
You know the system
also activates like
matrix metallopodiases
which are responsible
for remodeling
collagen so they're
part of the healing
process and they also
promote the production
of no red blood cells
which is referred
to as angiogenesis.
So this system is crucial
in repair and remodeling.
The kinase system is
actually integral to
inflammation and
especially in regard to
the production of the
chemical bradykinin.
So bradykinin is an
inflammatory mediator,
a powerful
which has multiple
different actions
like smooth muscle
contraction, it can
increase
vasculoperability, it can
cause dilation because
of the release of
nitric oxide, which
is a vasodilator.
So
But there are again
other mediators that
are also very important
as part of the
inflammatory response,
as we have discussed.
You know, leukotrienes
and prostaglandins,
very important.
Complement proteins,
C3A and C5A, all
trigger mast cell
degranulation, and
we'll talk a little
bit about mast cells
and their role.
IgE antibodies
synthesize mast cells and
basophils and cause
both of them to produce
histamine which is
also an inflammatory
mediator. On the right
side there there's a
youtube video that I
cannot play within the
video guys because of
copyright reasons but
you can go ahead and play
it off the powerpoint
and what that's
going to show you is
how a mast cell actually
degranulates and
responds to let's say
IgE and how it actually
dumps all these granulocytes
in the cytoplasm
that contain
histamine. So it's just
cool to see that
mast cell completely
disintegrating and basically
just produces massive
amount of histamine in
the vicinity whenever
it's activated. And
so of course, so
these cells, mast cells
and vasophils play a
very important role
in the inflammatory
response predominantly
through the secretion
of histamine. But they
also produce serotonin,
which is a vasodilator
and helps with
the increase of
vasculopirability and can
cause of course pain
which then can alert the
person that there's
some things going on.
And this is just a
table to show you the
many different types
of inflammatory
mediators that we talked
about from histamine,
the complement
proteins, bradykinin,
leukotrienes,
prostaglandins and their
main source what cells
make them and their
actions. It's a
pretty good table just
to kind of get an idea
of where all these
things come from
and their locations.
I I don't expect
you to memorize, of
course, all of this,
but just to kind of get
a grasp and understanding
and appreciation
to all these
inflammatory mediators.
One of the most crucial
things for the body
and the immune system
basically is to
recognize when there's
a foreign substance.
And the way to figure
out or the solution
for that is to actually
have what's called
pattern recognition
receptors which are
specific for foreign
substances and not not
our own antigens
but at the same time
broad enough to cover as
many foreign substances
as possible. It's
kind of a difficult
thing to do but
apparently the body was
able to figure that
out using these PRRs.
So pattern recognition
receptors are
crucial. They actually
are found all over
the body which is
good on many different
cells. What they do
is they recognize
pathogen-associated
molecular patterns
or PAMPs and basically
these are foreign
antigens that are
found on different
foreign substances
which the pattern
recondition receptors
can recognize. Make sure
you're aware of these
terminology both.
So examples of these,
these receptors can be
um classic receptors
that ones we found we
find on cells surfaces
for example like
toll-like receptors
which we're going to
talk about those but
some of those are
actually secreted
receptors that are found in
serum like c-reactive
protein or the manan
binding lectin which
is also important
for triggering complement
and some of them
are found inside the
cell. So intracytoplasmic
-like nod-like
receptors would be
examples of that and
we'll talk about those.
Nod-like receptors
are basically the name
comes from nucleotide
binding oligomization
domain because
these receptors bind
the same type of
nucleotide over and over.
So again, they bind
to these pathogen
-associated molecular
patterns, like things
like peptidoglycan,
which is found on
most bacteria, because
they have a cell
wall, or LPS, which
is found on gram
negatives, or let's
say single-stranded
RNA molecules that
are found in viruses,
okay?
These are coded
by our genome.
These receptors
do not undergo
rearrangement. They
don't differ from one
individual to another
among all human beings.
These are identical
and as such
allow all of us the
ability to recognize
these foreign
substances and as such
then trigger the
inflammatory response.
So what do the pattern
recognition receptors
do? Of course, as we
talk, they trigger
the inflammation.
The inflammatory
response is very
important and let the body
know that something
was wrong. So they
channel all these
systems and they It can
also mobilize the
infectious microbe to
prevent it from moving
into other places
in the body. They can
promote phycocytosis,
and they can
actually activate our
cells to produce
antimicrobial substances.
On the right side,
this table shows the
pattern recognition
receptor signaling
pathway. Just it's a
complex figure to look
at, but it's kind of
interesting to see
different types of
pattern recognition
receptors and the different
type of PAMPs that
they bind to and
how they relay that
information to cells.
Just look at it, take
it, so give you an
appreciation of how that
works. The point here
is not for you to
memorize any of this,
but at least maybe
sometime when you
visually see something
it will remind you of
these things later.
The next few slides
we're going to discuss
a few pattern recognition
receptors, let's
talk about a little
bit, at least key ones.
One of the pretty
important ones is C
-reactive protein, or CRP.
It's a very important
protein, it's a main
acute phase protein
produced by actually
parasites, or liver
cells, in response to
very important cytokine
IL-6, which is an
inflammatory cytokine.
The both importance
of CRP and IL-6
inflammation is definitely
understated. I'm not
sure if you guys have
been reading recently
about information,
but one of the key
things to figure out
if a COVID patient
will progress into a
severe case is to measure
IL-6. So IL-6 is
quite an an important
determinant in
figuring out if a COVID
patient would become
more severe case. And
also C-reactive proteins
on both of these.
So IL-6 levels should be
around like
three milligrams
per mil, but in some
patients it could
go all the way up
to 200, 300, even a
thousand. And that
of course suggests a
very severe infection
and quicker intervention
and probably poor
prognosis too.
but again these
markers are important
and there's also i
believe an il-6 receptor
i'm sorry i have
six blocker a drug
i can't remember
which kind of like
it's one of those
monoclonal antibodies
but you can look it up
and it's been suggested
to be used as therapy
for for severe cases
of covet um going back
to what we're talking
about here c-reactive
protein the importance
of your active protein
as a pan recognition
receptor it's part
of what's called the
pentexin, pentexin
family of proteins. They
call them that because
they have five subjects
for penta, penta5,
that form this ring.
C-reactive protein pro
-opsonizes microbes.
It's basically
tags in, you know,
microbes like nomococci,
which have capsules,
so they can be then
destroyed by phagocytes
and all recognized
by a complement.
And so those will do
that. And so CRP will
also activate the
classical complement
pathway and it can also
even bind to necrotic
and apoptotic cells
and cause them to be
cleared from our body so
it's a pretty important
protein and again
very important marker
of inflammation and
i'll give you an example
of covet patients but
also in like heart
disease and other and
other infections in
the last pattern
recognition receptors
we're going to
talk about what are
very important ones
and probably one of
the first discovered
pattern recognition
receptors. This
is when people
realize there's such
a thing as a pattern
recognition receptor
and this is how we
actually trigger
inflammation in our body
and that is toll-like
receptors. They call
them toll-like
because they are toll
receptors in E. coli
and these toll-like
receptors seem to share
homology with these
E. coli receptors.
That's where the name
comes from. It's not
hugely important.
Again toll-like
receptors are there's at
least 10 of them and
they're found in most
tissues in the body.
They can activate
tycosides, which then
can come and of course
become antigen
-presenting cells to
eventually trigger the
adaptive in response.
They can activate the
transcription factor
NF-kappa-B that we
talked about earlier in
the lecture. That's a
very important signal
transduction pathways
of inflammation.
And on the table
right here shows you
different types of
toll-like receptors
and the type of
PAMPs they bind to.
So like total
lycoceptor 1 is specific
to lipopeptides or
LPS, so it's pretty
much detects gram
-negative bacteria.
Total lycoceptor
3 is specific to
double-stranded RNA.
So of course we don't
have double
-stranded RNA in our
cells. This is typically
a viral species
or viral molecule.
So total lycoceptor
3 is very specific
to recognizing
viruses in the
body. Toll-like
receptor 4, LPS,
so gram-negatives,
and so on. As you
can see, you know,
Toll-like receptor
7 and 8, which
also recognize
single-strand RNA,
detect virions.
You know, and
people have seen,
actually, deficiencies
of Toll-like receptors,
for example,
it seems that
deficiency in Toll
-like receptor 3 makes
people more susceptible
to hepatitis,
sorry, ****** simplex
virus, SSV. Total
lycra receptor 7 seem
to be associated, or
deficiency in total
lycra receptor 7 seem
to be associated with
higher viral load
and disease progression
in HIV patients.
So these, the presence
of these receptors
and having them be
intact is important.
it. So let's talk
about fever as
part of the innate
immune response.
A second line
of difference.
We discovered
inflammation. So
fever is typically
induced by
what's called
either exogenous
substances like
LPS or endogenous
cytokines that are
in our body. Both
fever-inducing substances
are referred to
as pyrogens. That's
what that term means.
So LPS would be an
exogenous pyrogen,
while IL-1, IL-6 are
endogenous pyrogens.
Either way,
what's the purpose
and the benefit of fever?
Many actually,
and remember the
definition of fever is
you have to have
anywhere above 38 almost
degrees Celsius to
be considered fever.
so mild fluctuation
in temperature around
37 degrees celsius
is not really fever.
Either way the
rise in temperature
in our body actually
inhibits the
multiplication of
a lot of microbes
that especially
bacteria that do not
like that higher
end temperature so
so it inhibits their
growth. It can actually
impede nutrition of
bacteria by reducing
the amount of iron in
our body and it can
increase the metabolism
of our own enzymes
and stimulate immune
reactions and some
of the naturally
protective physiological
processes that we
have. So fever, as long
as it's controlled
and within reason, is
very beneficial in
fighting a pathogen.
Part of the second line
is a very important
group of molecules
known as interferons.
Of course, this
COVID pandemic has
really shed a light
on the significance
and important an
interferon and I'll
talk to you about
that a little bit.
So interferons is a
group of proteins.
There's actually three
major types
of interferon.
Actually there's two
types of interferons,
type 1 and type 2.
Type 1 interferons are
the alpha and beta
which are the antiviral
interferons and then
there's the type 2 which
is the interferon
gamma which is more of
a immune regulator.
So Let's focus on the
type one interferon,
which is the alpha and
beta. Alpha is made by
dendritic cells, while
beta is made by
fibroblasts, but they both
have antiviral properties.
Typically, what
they do is they block
the mRNA synthesis
of the virus and
activate apoptosis
of the cell,
thereby killing the
cell that the
virus is infected.
There's been a
significant amount of
information recently
talking about the role
of interferon alpha
and the level of
interferon alpha in
patients that have COVID.
So the higher interferon
alpha, the better
the outcomes. And also
this also explains
why children don't
seem to have severe
COVID is because they
normally have a high
level of interferon
alpha. Children in
general don't have
a very well adaptive
immune response. Usually
it ticks that will
become teenagers
were to fully develop
so they rely more on
the innate immunity.
And relying more
on innate immunity
is not a bad thing
because you can
block the virus to
start with before
things get out of
hand. So there's been
several articles
that talks about
the level of Enderfuran
Alpha and its
relationship to the
severity of COVID.
So again really important
the stuff we're
talking about here
and quite timely
and significant.
On the other hand,
interferon gamma
is a is a very
important regulatory
molecule. It can
actually regulate
and induce MHC
molecules and enhance
co-stimulatory
molecules in antigen
-presenting cells.
It can induce like
adhesion and chemokines
on antithelial cells.
So it just plays
many different
roles in regulating
the immune response.
It could even activate
macrophages and
make them more
microcedal. It can
promote class switching
by antibodies,
sorry, by B cells to
switch antibodies.
It can actually
play a big role
in regulating TH1 and TH2
population because
interferon gamma
favors the TH1 response,
which we'll talk
about in the next
lecture, which is the
adaptive beam response.
But this again where
the innate immune
response and the adaptive
immune response
interplay. and interferon
gamma is one of
those in the next few
slides we're going to
be discussing the system
known as complement
which is an integral
part of the innate
second-level defense
so complement the name
actually comes from
because it complements
the immune system
when people discovered
it that's where it
came from it's basically
a group of like 16
proteins that are
found in serum all
produced by liver cells
so that's important then
the function of liver,
they actually make
up almost 10 percent
of serum proteins.
They are made inactive,
so the complement
proteins, excuse
me, are made and
they're inactive
in the serum, but
then they're
inactivated on the spot.
It's probably one of
the older systems,
you know, from
evolution in that sense.
And there are three
different ways
to activate complement
in the body.
They were, the discovery,
the way it's listed
there, A, B, and C, is
listed by discovery.
People discovered
the classical pathway
first, and the alternative
pathway, and then
the menand-binding
mectin. But that's not
how they are actually
activated in real
life. So let's just
talk about each briefly,
and the function of
complement next few slides,
and then discuss
this so the classical
pathway from the name
they referred to it
that way because that's
the common way over
the the first time that
you know compliment
was activated and that's
typically occurs by
the presence of
antigens and antibodies
whenever we have an
antigen antibody binds to
it these two combination
of two with those
complexes can actually
activate the classical
pathway. Clearly, if
you have to have an
antibody, that means
you've already activated
T helper cells,
probably TH17 or TH2,
and then you've made
antibodies, you know,
sorry, then activated B
cells to became plasma
cells to make antibodies.
So that's a long
process and that's
clearly takes more to
activate complement
hours. You have to have
the adaptive immune
response fully activated
um to activate the
classical pathway so
it's actually the the
pathway that activates
the latest on the other
hand the alternative
pathway is the one
that's activated first
the alternative
pathway is actually has
a very mild it's
almost like it's
constantly on a low
level of activation very
low level and it's
immediately like
triggered to go all the
way up The alternative
pathway is activated
by microbial
products like LPS or
peptidoglycan. If you
add those things in
blood or serum, it
will activate the
alternative pathway.
And then there's
the manan-binding
lectin pathway. And
that's actually activated
by manan, which
is a sugar that's
found on some
bacterial cells. And so
that's also a quick
pathway that's also
activated early on
in the process. So
the classical tends
to be the latest.
Either way, the
complement cascade, guys,
reminds me a lot of
the cloud and cascade.
They're very similar
in both of them.
They both work on
positive feedback.
They both have a
common pathway.
Eventually, everything
funnels the same
thing. They all have
multiple ways by
which you can activate
them. So either
way, classical,
alternative, or man-man,
eventually results
in the activation
of C3 protein, or
complement 3 protein,
and that breaks apart
into C3B and C3A.
C3A, as we talked already,
is an inflammatory
chemical, so
that can serve as
that purpose. Now,
the C3B goes on and
activates C5. Now, C5
becomes C5A and C5B.
C5A is an inflammatory
chemical again.
C5b goes on and
activates what's called
the membrane attack
complex, which is a
combination of C5b,
C6, C7, C8, and C9.
And then we'll talk
about what happens with
the membrane attack
complex and what's
achieved after that.
So that's typically how
the complement system
is activated, but we'll
discuss the rest in
the next few slides.
So here let's talk a
little bit about complement
function. What does
complement do? So
complement has multiple
functions as you can
see here, five different
essential functions
but the really the
most important one and
the most unique one
to complement is
obstinization the reason
i say that is because all
the other four
functions are redundant
function two three four
or five on this slide
are redundant with other
things in other words
you can have other
components of the immune
system chipping in
or compensating for
lack of complement but
the obstinization tends
to be an issue so if
complement is deficient
then obstinization
ends up being a problem
so again we talked
about obstinization
before it's a key process
basically it's tagging
foreign substances
for destruction
predominantly the most
effective way for complement
to obstinize is
capsulated bacteria so
while capsules are very
difficult to process
very difficult like
we talked about last
semester in the bacterial
physiology lecture.
They're difficult to
clear, they survive
longer, they can
avoid antibodies
and so on. So
opsonizing a capsule is
critical to greater
capsulated organisms.
So whenever we
see complement
deficiency, the first
thing we notice is a
patient becomes
highly susceptible to
capsulated bacteria.
So capsulization is
actually done by C3B and
C4B, these two complement
components that
are important. But does
complement have other
functions? Sure, Like
number two, formation
of the membrane attack
complex, which we
just discussed in the
previous slide, or MAC,
and that is the
combination of C5B, C6,
C7, C8, and C9. All
these form a hole
in the cell membrane
of, let's say,
bacteria or envelope
viruses and pokes
hole in them. So
it's basically you're
poking hole in the
cell or the viral
envelope and you both
lose the integrity.
So that's an important
function, but
that can be also
performed by other parts
of the system. For
example, you know,
T-cellotoxic cells can
do that. Microphages
can live and kill
bacteria, neutrophils.
Also, we just talked
about that several
times now, the
byproducts of the
activation of C3 and
C5 results in C3A and
C5A. Both are
inflammatory chemicals
and mediators that
can do all the
inflammation that we
talked about before.
Also, complements need
to help with priming
B cells and provide
us with a much
more efficient antibody
response. They can
also help clear immune
complexes in the
body and cells that
are destined to die.
So to highlight
the importance
of complement
in opsonization,
a lot of experiments
were done on depleting,
for example, mice
from complement and
seeing how they
respond, specifically
complement C30s. If you
do that for mice, for
example, C depleted
mice or C deficient
mice seem to have a
much lower antibody
response. Now granted,
mice immune responses
are different from
humans, but nevertheless
we can still learn
a lot from them.
You know, C opsonized
particles, so particles
that are opsonized
by complement tend
to be a thousand
times more active at
triggering antibodies
production and be cleared
than unopsonized
particles so clearly
complement aids the
immoral immune response
which is of course
the antibody response.
C3V seems to have
many functions like
helping with B cell
maturation and migration
to actually avoid
organs activating
B cells by helping
the mind to be
opsonized and promoting
oxidized antigens and
helping dendritic
cells to select for
the correct B cell
that they activate.
Dendritic cells, if
you remember, are
very important antigen
-presenting cells,
like follicle
dendritic cells.
And like we talked about,
complement can
be activated by
the classical
pathway or the
lectin pathway or
the alternative
pathway. So again,
with the classical
pathway, just to
reiterate, you
have to have an
antigen antibody.
Typically, the antibody
is either RGM or
IgG. IgM is much
more efficient at
activating complement
because of its pentameric
structure. If you
remember, it's got
a large structure,
it can activate a lot
more complement than
IgE, for example.
And it kind of makes
sense because it's
one of the first
antibody response.
For lectin, as we
talked about, presence
of manan or mannose,
for example, can
activate the manan
-lectic pathway. It's
that carbohydrate
and components of the
cell wall like the
n-acetylcocosamine.
We mentioned a little
bit the alternative
pathway is usually under
a very low constant
state of activation,
so it's always
ready and it's always
the first one. Typically
required magnesium,
a factor called B,
all important ones, and
it's usually activated
by surface foreign
substances like LPS.
This table kind of helps
you summarize like,
for example, the role
of different microbes,
the role of immunoglobulins
and activating
pathways. For
example, the classical
pathway immune complex
is having IgM and
different subtypes where
you can activate them.
and so on and for
example different type
of organisms that are
microorganisms that
can activate complement
so this is showing
you the the full
pathway of complement
again no need to
memorize this that's
not the point but
just to see how the
different points where
the activating things
happens, for example
the classical, the
alternative and the
lexin, and how they all
funnel to the C3,
which then becomes
splits to C3A and C3B,
and then C3B converts
C5 to C5A and C5B,
and then that goes
on activates the
membrane attack complex.
This slide shows
the membrane attack
complex. On the right
side there you see an
electron micrograph
of the membrane attack
complex embedded
into the membrane of
a bacterium. These
holes are basically
the membrane attack
complex basically forming
these complexes and
of course this causes
the membrane to leak
and the cells to
lose integrity and
eventually they're lice.
This table presents the
different complement
deficiencies. You'll
also have lectures
on complement
deficiencies from some
of our clinical faculty
so this will help
you at least have a
basis for that. So
you can see different
comparable deficiencies
that can happen
along the way and
the consequence of
that. So, for example,
deficiencies
in preparidin,
P on the right bottom
side there, can
predispose people to
meningococcal meningitis.
Preparidin
deficiency, for
example, is an x-linked
deficiency that's
inherited that way and
males are of course more
predisposed to that.
But if you look
at in general, no
matter where
deficiencies, deficiencies
in C5, deficiencies
in factor D,
but they all basically
result in severe
recurrent bacteria
infections and more often
capsulated bacteria,
capsulated bacteria.
And again, that
goes back to the
importance of obstinization
for complement.
Also, you'll see some
in other places there
talks about like lupus
-like disease sometimes
in activity a deficiency
can cause that
there's also polymorphisms
and C3 protein
that can results let's say
in macular degeneration
so complement seem
to play a lot of
different roles so the
question arises how
do we protect our own
cells from complement
once it becomes active
and how do we also
protect complement proteins
from being consumed
and degraded and
basically use them so
there's actually several
mechanisms that are
deployed by the body
to protect complement
to protect ourselves
from complement and
protect also complement
components so there are
systems that prevent
consumption of the
complement components
for example if you see
on this table there
are several like decay
accelerating factors
CD55 basically delays
complement from being
used and defaults into
stopping, for example,
MAC formation, you
know, in that way you
can, unless it actually
finds a membrane of
a foreign substance.
Looking at, for
example, membrane
cofactor protein
CD46, that actually
protects our own
membranes from complement.
There's also another
one called CD59,
which we'll discuss
on the next slide.
That also protects
our own, it's found
on receptors of our
own cells, and it
protects our own
membranes from activation.
And so these actually,
these existing
um substances both
protect from being
consumed and protect us
from being attacked by
here is the cd59 that
we're talking about
and this complement
component is important
and it's found in a
lot of our cells as
broadly expects
throughout tissues in the
body it inhibits
actually the binding of
c9 and without c9 you
cannot form the mac
if you remember mac
is c5b C6, C7, C8,
and C9. And C9 is the
major component here,
and so without that
you cannot form MAC.
And this is kind of
illustrated with people
that have actually
deficiencies in expression
of CD59. These
individuals develop what's
called proxysmal
nocturnum hemoglobinuria,
and the reason it's
named that way is
because, you know, over
time when they wake up
in the morning their
urine becomes black
because as they sleep
breakdown of the blood
cells accelerates and
it just accumulates
so sometimes
confused a lot with
like hemolytic
anemia pancycopenia
and so on it
makes it so much
similar to that
so it's kind of
difficult sometimes
to diagnose let's
switch topics and talk
about how phycocytes
arrive at the site
of inflammation how
do they get to the
site, how do they leave
the bloodstream and
arrive at the actual
tissue, and how do they
get to exactly where
the antigen is and
how I'm in on that
location. Several
things are at play here.
Phagocytes first
follow a chemokine
gradient, so the
more there are
chemokines, the more
they'll chase that.
It's basically
concentration dependent.
There's over 50
different kind
of chemokines
and they can be
secreted in different
concentrations.
Phagocytes have
chemokine receptors that
allow them to interact
with these chemokines,
and then they
basically follow that
gradient to get
to exactly where
the antigen is.
But of course
before that they
have to leave
the circulation,
and to do that they
use their integrins,
surface receptors,
cell surface
receptors or CAMs, and
integrins basically
then bind to selectives,
and selectives are
also receptors that
are found on the
endothelial cells,
the squamous cells
of the blood vessels.
uh once the civic
integrand binds that
specific selectin they
will um excuse me bind
to the wall of the
etothenium roll the cell
will roll and then
find the space between
two squamous cells
and then by a process
called diacodesis they'll
squeeze in between
and then keep continuing
to following that
chemokine gradient
until they get to the
exact location of that
foreign substances
which then they can
you know put those
more cytokines
and or phagocytide
to sell whatever they
need to do to deal
with that foreign
substance here's
an example of
different type of
chemokines and their
receptors and you can
see here so there's
you know there's again
we talked about
there's at least 50
different kind of
chemokines and the receptors
are called so the
chemokines are CC you
know chemokine chemicals
and their receptors
are called CCRs you
know so like CCR5
and CXCR3 are are both
chemokine receptors
and if those seem to
ring a bell these are
also two receptors
that HIV binds to to
actually gain entry
into both macrophages
and T helper cells so
so take note of that.
And yeah, so the variation
of these different
receptors and ligands
as a result can
determine which
leukocytes get to which
tissue. That's how you
can get that selectivity.
Now of course there
are defects in
sometimes in these
particular receptors and
when that happens you
end up with inefficiency
and inability to
hone these leukocytes
to a certain location
and subsequently, for
example, you can't
get rid of infections,
foreign substances.
So one example
of that is locus
side adhesion
deficiency syndrome
or LAD syndrome.
And that's really a
defect in the production
of the receptors,
you know, called beta
integrins, which we
just talked about. They
bind to the selectors
of the therial ones.
LAD patients typically
suffer from life
-threatening both bacterial
and fungal infections
and cannot actually
form abscesses. so they
cannot like you know
basically deal and
kill a foreign substance
so the neutrophils
don't really work very
well at the same time
this knowledge can give
us some applications
for example you can use
monoclonal antibodies
against specific
ligands like let's say
v-cams and block them.
So, for example, in
multiple sclerosis
patients where the, where
our immune system
cells, specifically T
-cells, attack the myelin,
you can prevent these
T-cells from migrating
this into the nervous
system by simply
blocking the ligand on,
let's say, the
oligodendrocytes and then
subsequently the T-cells
will just simply not
migrate there. So,
it's kind of a really
neat way of since you
know that this is the
cause so these could
be like therapeutic
applications obviously
these are not available
yet but hopefully they
show a lot of promise
so we spoke about we
spoke about phycocytosis
phycocyte chemotaxis
so let's switch
and talk about the
actual process of
phycocytosis phycocytosis
part of the innate
immune response is
it's part of the second
line along with
inflammation along with
complement and other
systems we talked about,
thagocytes is
critically important.
Thagocytes, as you can
see from the figure
on top there, top
left, express many
different receptors,
toll-like receptors,
you know, FCR
receptors, these are
for antibodies,
complement receptors,
receptors for defensins,
like those molecules
that are produced,
and so on. So there's
many, many receptors.
They use these receptors
to bind to different
molecules and they
also combine and also
recognize pathogens.
And so that's the first
key step is first to
attach, you know, to
the receptor. And then
second is to recognize
whether this substance
you bind to, do you
want to... is it
the foreign or is it
self? So that's very
important. Typically
our cells produce like
molecules called CD47s
and these molecules tell
a phagocyte that we
are self-antigens so
you don't have to
destroy us and so after
that step the phagocyte
basically will let go
of that particular
cell. If that cell is
getting old and dying
sometimes they don't
express as many of these
CD47s and subsequently
the phagocyte will
destroy itself and
that's a good thing
because these cells are
actually dying anyway
and need to be cleared.
Again so if it's
a dying cell or if
it's a pathogen then
the phagocyte will
recognize there's
something to destroy
and then they will
start engulfing it.
Of course using
axiom polymerization
they'll form a
phagosome and then once
the phagosome is
inside the cell
they'll fuse it
with light zones. Of
course light zones
have digestive enzymes
and other degradative
substances.
A drop of pH takes
place here and as a
result the enzymes become
active and you form
what's called a
phagolysosome and the
phagolysosome becomes
active and you digest
the substance and
eventually hopefully you
expel the debris from
breaking down or in
the case of like
macrophages or dendritic
cells which are also
dendritic cells they
can present those
pieces of the pathogen
on the surface on MHC
class tools, right,
for antigen presentation.
And we'll discuss
antigen presentation
in the, we've discussed
it last semester,
a part of the,
that immunity, but
we'll discuss it
also this time.
So again, a very
important process, just
recognize that a lot
of pathogens have
evolved different ways
to avoid phagocytosis,
like we've talked
about how capsules
are difficult to for
the phagocytes to
attach and recognize
but there's other
pathogens that have
evolved ways for example
some pathogens prevent
the phagosome from
the lysone to fuse
or when they do fuse
they prevent the pH
from drop or sometimes
they'll escape the
phagosome and so on
so so far we've
kind of talked about
how phagocytes can
recognize mainly
extracellular
pathogens like
a bacterium.
What happens if
the pathogen is
intracellular?
How is that recognized?
So there's actually
silozoic receptors
specifically
designed to recognize
intracellular pathogens.
These are part of the
pattern recognition
receptors that we
discussed before.
And so we talked about
pattern recognition
receptors, we talked
about toll-like
receptors, c-reactive
protein and so on, but
these are also very
important and they're
recognized in the
cellular pattern. Examples
of those receptors are
nod-like receptors.
For example, nod-like
receptors recognize
peptoclican, let's
say chunks of it,
with noic acid-inducible
gene 1-like helicases.
These specific
receptors, I
know it's a
wrong and earful,
recognize double
-strand RNA.
And so there are
many ways to also
recognize, and that's
crucial to that.
Nod-like receptors
actually form part of
what's called the
inflammasome so they can
trigger inflammation
and cell death in the
actual cell that's
infected by the pathogen.
So these are
important, they play
a very important
role. For example,
Nod polymorphisms
have been found among
individuals and peoples
and they've noticed
that if people have
these mutations
they can be let's say
more higher risk of
Crohn disease more
bacterial infections
and they can have a
little more IgE which
can trigger more
allergies they are more
prone to eczemas and
even eczemas so it's
kind of an interesting
clinical associations
with these receptors
and their role
so you we have talked
about different types
of phagocytes and
histology and so on so
it's kind of a review
but it's an important
review for you to
remember that you know
phagocytes are mainly
divided into two major
types polymorphonuclear
cells and mononuclear
cells there's also
another terminology
and they're both
equally important
polymorphonuclear
cells are also
called granulocytes
and mononuclear cells
are called agranulocytes
and the combination
of terminology
actually helps identify
these cells. So
polymorphonuclear cells
or granulocytes have a
polymorphic nucleus.
They have one nuclei but
it's shaped weird and
that's how you can
tell them. But they also
are granulocytes which
means they have granules
in their cytoplasm.
If the granules don't
show up with the
HME stain, in other
words to stain neutrally
those are called
neutrophils from neutral
granules if they're
stains with eosin which
is usually pink the
granules those are
called eosinophils
and if the stains are
stained with hematoxalan
which is the blue dye
which is also basic
they're called basophils
so that's where the
terms neutrophils
eosinophils or basophils
come from is actually
from the type of
reaction with the stain.
Mononuclear cells,
mononucleus, they
simply have a regular
size nucleus, just kind
of nice and spherical,
usually large,
but they're also called
agranulocytes because
they don't have
any granules in
the cytoplasm.
And those would
be your monocytes,
macrophages, of
course they're
monocytes when they're
in circulation,
macrophages when
they're in tissue,
dendritic cells,
now osteoclasties
are all part of
the malnuclear
cells and things
like microglia
which are also
type of macrophages
here on the right
side shows the kind
of precursor and how
you form different
macrophages and
andritic cells they all
originate from one
main cell originally in
bone marrow and
differentiate into different
types of cells on
the on the bottom
right side that red
picture with the green
that's actually an
eosinophil kind of a
really neat thing was
so you can see the
eosinophil nuclei stay
in red and the cytoplasm
stay in green, the
fluorescence stain.
But what you're seeing
is what eosinophils
kind of do is they
actually fling their DNA
from their cell. They
just like fling it out
and use it to trap
worms. Because remember
eosinophils are anti
-worm and they're very
effective at doing that.
So they use the DNA
kind of like to trap
the worms and the worms
can't move much because
DNA is very sticky.
It's almost like throwing
glue on an animal.
And this particular
slide just shows you a
different population
of macrophages found
all over the body. You
are almost familiar
with a lot of these
different names. For
example, in the liver,
we call them kufra cells.
In the lungs, they're
called alveolar
macrophages. Sometimes
they're called bust
cells. In the skin, we
call them length of hand
cells. In the central
nervous system we
call microglia but
these are all basically
macrophages nothing new
and it's just a list
for you don't need to
memorize that but as
you encounter these
different cells you just
remember that these
are all macrophages
this slide shows a
comparison between the two
major fagocytes that
we all talk about
neutrophils and macrophages
so it's important
to kind of i think you
already know a lot of
these so let's just
put them in one place
for example for
neutrophils they're short
-lived they're involved
in the acute response
so they're Typically,
the first thymicocytes
arrive at a site
of an inflammation.
They're really
responsible for
fast clearance
of the pathogen.
They have tons of
antimicrobial peptides,
lots of defencins and
so on that they can
use on pathogens, and
they can also produce
oxygen radicals to
kill the pathogen.
That's it in regard to
neutrophils.
For macrophages,
they're long-lived,
and so they're really
more so involved in
chronic inflammation
infection. Remember,
macrophages also
regulate the inflammatory
response, and
they're the ones that
invite neutrophils.
They're not as
micro-racidal and as
cytotoxic as
neutrophils. Neutrophils
are just a lot
more notorious.
But, you know, as
long as they, the
longer they stay
there, they can
actually accumulate
that toxicity.
As we talked about, they
recruit neutrophils.
They require
activation by pattern
recognition receptors,
and they actually display
a little higher degree
of specificity which
makes them better as
sentinels of the immune
system like dendritic
cells and again
that specificity is still
broad because remember
they're still part
of the innate immune
response and as typical
of all white blood
cells they all produce
cytokines this is
just a slide that shows
the main cytokines that
phagocytes produce. For
example, interleukin
-1, which causes
fever, it's a pyrogen.
TNF-alpha, major
the producer of
inflammation,
which is secreted
by macrophages,
and other interleukins
like IL-8, IL-12,
which are raw and
attractive, like neutrophils
and natural fuel
cells. On the right
side there shows,
again, a comparing
contrast between two
major monoclear cells,
which are enderitic
cells and macrophages.
Again, the enderitic
cells are really
predominantly for
antigen presentation,
especially to naive
T cells. They're also
involved in educating T
cells, so differentiation
of different type
of T cells, while
macrophages are
the one really more
into, you know, regulation
of the inflammatory
response, actual
killing of the
pathogen, but they can
also do presentation.
We have discussed
this before, we
discussed the process
of phagocytosis
and that some
microbes use different
mechanisms to
evade phagocytosis
like capsules. We
talked about that.
The pathogen
M. tuberculosis
habits phagolysosome
fusion. This is why
tuberculosis or the
pathogen can stay in the
body for a very long
period of time and why
it can reactivate down
years years down the
road by basically hiding
inside macrophages
typically in the
phagolytosome or
at least sorry
in the phagosome
which is also why it
takes so long to treat TB
is to get rid
of all these you
know M. tuberculosis
bacteria
or bacilli that are
sitting inside those.
L monocyte genes can
actually escape the
phagosome prior to the
phagolytosome fusing
and the inside genes
makes a hemolycin
called the stereolysin
which can poke hole
in the phagosome
membrane and escape it.
Also in response to
this macrophages can
actually stimulate their
own self-destruction
basically it's called
autophagy and so
that's basically in
response to let's say if
M tuberculosis continue
to stay inside the
macrophage the macrophage
cannot clear it
The macrophage then
stimulates its own
degradation with the purpose
of getting rid itself
of the pathogen. So
you'll see that in a
lot of chronic bacterial
infections because
chronic bacteria
basically reside in these
monocytes for an
extended period of time.
And that's one of the
mechanisms to
get rid of it.
Disregulation of
autophagy will
result in prolonged
inflammation and
delayed clearance
of this pathogen.
And then just talk
a little bit about
different types of
macrophages. So predominantly
macrophages fall
into two different
lineages, M1 and M2,
and there's a distinct
difference between
these two macrophages.
M1 tend to be more
inflammatory, M1
macrophages they
tend to respond to
interferon gamma, they
tend to kill more and
that's really more
if so inflammatory
microcedal type of
um microphage while
the m2 are more into
repair they're less
microcedal they're
not as inflammatory
in that regard and
so so sometimes
microbes can exploit
so you know like so
like francisella
tolerances will will
cause my microphages
to shift more to
the m2 type so they're
not as microcedal
But they both are
important in the body, so
what you want to do is
start out maybe with
M1 types and kill
the pathogen and all
that, but then eventually
you want to switch
more to an M2 because
at some point you
want to resolve that,
or at least once the
microbes are killed,
you don't want to just
keep killing tissue and
causing more damage,
and now you still
want to induce repair.
So you should see a
shift from M1 to M2.
but you don't want to
start with an m2 because
then you're not going
to get clearance
of that pathogen just
flushing out a little
bit the macrophage
regulation we can see here
both the pro-inflammatory
m1 macrophages
are typically stimulated
by interferon gamma
which is also
secreted by both
macrophages themselves
so it's kind of
a positive feedback
And additionally,
my specialty T
-helper-1 cells.
So those are sometimes
called classically
activated, the M1s,
macrophages, and they're
pretty much involved
in inflammation,
you know, and
killing of the
antichocytosis
of the cell,
rather than
healing and repair.
DH-17 cells, or T
-helper-17 cells, which
we'll discuss later
through their IL
-17, can also cause
macrophages to become
more inflammatory
in their reaction.
On the other hand,
Th2 cells or T
helper 2 through IL
-4 and IL-13 switch
the phenotype of
the macrophage
into more of the
wound healing type,
basically what we
refer to as M2 or
alternatively activated
sometimes they call.
Either way a dysfunction
of both of these
can happen if the if
m2 microphages are
overexpressed you can
get fibrosis because
they can just cause
a lot of healing
too much basically
and of course m1 can
cause too much damage
through inflammation.
So
let's switch and talk
about the last innate
cells referred to
as natural killer
cells. Again very
important cells lymphocytes
if you remember with
lymphocytes there's
t cells b cells and
natural kill cells
they're the least
dominant of the kill
of the lymphocytes
these cells are most
common than B cells
and then natural kill
cells composed probably
like one to three
percent of all
lymphocytes but they are
very very important
cells they can innately
engage antigen they
don't have memory
but they can
recognize both vital
infected cells and
tumor cells and kill
kill them on the spot
how do they do that
they have basically
receptors referred
to as killer
activation receptors,
CARs.
And the counter to
that, they also have
what's called killer
inhibition receptors,
which those prevent them
from killing our own
cells. So usually
if a virus infects a
cell, these viruses
will tend to, sorry, not
the viruses, but the
cells then tend to
display with stress
molecules or stress
associated molecules
called MYC-A and MICB and
basically MIC or MIC
stands for MHC class 1
polypeptide related
sequence and so they'll
display MCC class 1
related sequences which
are showing that they
have these stresses.
At the same time
viruses can cause the
MHC class 1 to be
depressed. That's kind of
a mechanism that the
viruses will do. Either
way the natural kill
cells will recognize
these MICA and MICB
through their cars
and that result in death
of that cell so once
engagement happened
natural kill cells
can make also like
perforans and granzymes
which can kill either
poke holes into the
cell or cause it to
undergo epoptosis well
natural kill cells
can you know the cure
receptors will constantly
go around and assess
the MHC class 1 and
if it's devoid of any
foreign substance then
they will just leave
the cell B and this
ensures that natural
killer cells do not
attack our own cells.
The next few slides
is going to just give
you a little introduction
to primary immune
deficiencies. There's
primary differences
and secondary immune
deficiencies and
you guys will have
actual lectures on each.
I just want to give
you just a little
bit of a heads up
basically before you
start and to also
allow you some clinical
relevance the
information we're talking
about so everything
we've talked
about in regard to
innate immune response
we can have
deficiencies in any
of those and those
can result in
um obviously
diseases for example
defects in phagolyzone
fusion occurs in
Shidiak-Higashi
syndrome which is a
phagocyte disorder
and of course these
predispose these
individuals to infections
and chronic
granulomatous disease and
there's a defect in the
ability of macrophages
to actually produce
oxygen radicals
this predisposes
these individuals
for example
to like fungal
diseases like
aspergulosis
there are individuals
with interferon
gamma receptor deficiency
and as you know
interferon gamma
is a very important
cytokine especially
with th1 and cell
mediated immune response
so that basically
takes out their self
-mediating response.
And we talked
today about LAD
leukocyte adhesion
deficiency
and how that
will prevent, for
example, neutrophils
and macrophages
to reach the site
of inflammation,
which then
predispose these
individuals
to infections.
There's
also complement
disorders that can also
predispose individuals
to several infections.
We've talked about
those a little bit.
Now, many of
those predispose
individuals to
encapsulate the bacteria.
So there's defects
in alternative
pathway and
mendenlectin pathway,
there's defects in
classical pathway.
So deficiencies in
like C1, C2, and
C4, and those like
make immune complexes
very difficult to
clear, which results
in more type 3
hypersensitivities.
And we talked about
deficiency in
complement regulation
with hereditary
injury *****
because individuals
don't express
the protective
complement component
which then complement
ends up lysing
red blood cells
overnight and
resulting in that
dark urine so anyway
just a brief
introduction you'll have
actual lectures
separate ones
on primary immune
deficiencies
So with this lecture we
focused predominantly
on the innate immune
response. We initially
compared the innate
and the adaptive a
little bit and then we
split the innate response
into the primary or
sorry first line of
defense and second line
of defense. First line
of defense was like
the physical chemical
and biological barriers
that we talked about
and then we fleshed
out the second line of
defense as we talked
about the inflammation,
complement, phagocytosis,
natural kill
sub-response and
all the other
ones we discussed.
And initially in
the end we talked
just briefly about
a few phagocytes and
complement deficiencies
and the type
of diseases they're
associated with.